من هذا المكان قفز المعتدي وهو يصرخ بكلام
غير مفهوم نحو مدخل الحديقه التي كان
يتنزه فيها عدد من السياح والسكان
المحليين كان هناك اطفال داخل عرباتهم
يحرسهم ذووهم انقض المعتدي بسكين على طفل
هولندي يبلغ من العمر 22 شهرا
ثم على طفل بريطاني في عامه الثاني ثم على
طفلين شقيقين فرنسيين هم اخ في الثانيه من
عمره واخته في الثالثه من عمرها كما اصيب
بجراح خطره رجل مسن واخر اقل سنا اصيب
ايضا ولكن بجراح طفيفه المعتدي لا يتعاون
مع الشرطه حتى الان
وقد قال تطلقته التي اتصلت بها احدى وسائل
الاعلام انه مسيحي سوري من مدينه الحسكه
تحديدا كان تقدم بطلبات اللجوء في كل من
ايطاليا وسويسرا والسويد وقبلت طلبات
اللجوء كلها ثم اصر على طلب اللجوء في
فرنسا لكن طلب اللجوء هنا رفض في السادس
والعشرين من نيسان ابريل الماضي وقد ابلغ
المعتدي بهذا الرفض قبل اربعه ايام من
ارتكاب جريمته فهل يكون هناك بل تكون هناك
علاقه بين هذا الرفض وبين الجريمه سؤال
سيجيب عنه التحقيق المتواصل الذي سيجيب
ايضا على اسئله اخرى كثيره حسين قنيبر
للعربيه والحدث من مدينه انسي فرنسا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات